everyone
our next speaker is Marine fule and he
will talk about trusted automaticism
thanks Alex
so uh it's very nice to talk here about
uh this this uh important topic Randy
already introduced and motivated it
quite a bit so I will uh so I will talk
about as well I will illustrate various
things using some mathematical examples
uh I make sure that there's no overlap
with the talk I gave uh two weeks ago
here but there is there is some overlap
at least a bit of the uh the talk I gave
in Berkeley uh earlier this week
um so but
I will go more into detail here so that
was more a higher level
so let me start with this slide that
might many of you have already seen
um when they submitted the supposed
result on archive we were contacted by
Nature I tried to explain to her in 70
minutes by this it was so important that
we could trust the results
and but none of that got into the
article right it's more that this is
somehow a an honor but it's quite a
dubious honor of making the the largest
mathematics proof uh and of course as
all of you know it's very easy to make
it larger just making the heuristic work
slightly but
um and uh but the cool thing so I think
the positive story here is that even if
the proofs are 200 terabytes in size or
for the sure number five it's even two
petabytes in size we can validate these
proofs and we can validate them using
formerly verified Checkers so I think
this is all about the trust uh story and
as Randy already mentioned this turned
out to be quite addictive so you once
you have a proof for something you want
to have a proof of everything and um
so that's also what I've been pursuing
you're probably almost in this so you
I've just kind of four introduction
slides but so for everybody that did not
see this problem so uh the big proof
came from the packaging triple's problem
um
a jack already mentioned this uh
regarding Rado numbers
so we want to color the positive
integers we have two colors let's call
them red and blue such there's no
monochromatic solution of the the
equation a square plus b squared is c
squared
you can easily do this episode 40 by
hand it's just if the number is a
single prime factor of five or seven it
is uh blue and otherwise it's red and
you can easily make easy constructions
up till even a couple of thousands but
uh
uh things get hard at seven thousand so
uh almost a decade ago uh Cooper and
Overstreet actually two students of
Graham uh were able to a former students
were able to uh get to 7664 and Myers
actually in a species contextual that
you could do this indefinitely just kind
of for everybody here is kind of kind of
natural how it would translate this into
propositional logic we go trying to find
that counter sample for a range from one
to n and for each number in the range we
introduce a proposition of variable x i
if I is assigned to true of x i is
assigned to true it means I is red and
if x i is assigned to false uh
triple we have two Clauses one stating
at least one of A or B is V or C is red
and at least one of a or b or c
right so this problem is extremely easy
to uh convert to propositional logic in
contrast to several of the others I
won't talk about and the result that we
had was you can color numbers one to
seven thousand eighteen or twenty four
but you cannot go beyond that
and actually this results over here
can now be done by local search in 30
seconds
right uh so if Cooper and Overstreet
would have used kind of the
state-of-the-art local search they would
have also been able to reproduce this
results
uh our main tried to reproduce these
results using uh lingerling uh he run it
12 core playing a link for uh 300 days
on the 12 core machine and then there
was a power outage and he didn't want to
restart
this was done using on the on this on
the UT Austin cluster in four CPU years
but in two days running 800 cores if we
had the entire cluster then we could
have done it in half an hour
right but the important thing is so note
that the proof is that big but that we
can verify the validated using formerly
verified Checkers and we actually have
now four four formerly verified checkers
one in acl2 one in Isabel and kkml
that actually check this
and one exciting thing is also that
not only that this community or a
broader kind of automated reasoning
Community is interested in it's much
broader and even Fields medalists are
now interested in this uh so uh and that
wasn't used not to be the case for
example uh the packaging triples
approved uh gowers mentioned almost
blocked that it's the most disgusting
proof ever
um
but he was also one of the co-organizers
of a workshop that we had two months ago
at IBM on machinist proof and also carry
Tau and so there's a lot of excitement
about using uh machine learning
automated reasoning to find proofs for
mathematical problems
okay so that was the introduction I will
talk about three topics first I will
explain okay how how did we make it so
possible right and it's not not all the
trivial then I would like to talk about
going Beyond proof checking we actually
not only do the the proofs uh tell us
whether the results was correct or not
there's actually quite some things you
can get out of it and uh this is one
thing that we are kind of also working
on now how to get even further trust in
the whole tool check
so this is a slider borrowed from Randy
all right so what we're going to do is
so you have your propositional formula
you give it to a subsover and it
produces a proof of unsatisfiability
that can be checked right and this works
because the proof Checker is a much more
simple program and ideally formally
verified
so this idea was already as already
mentioned uh in 2003 there were two
groups that already worked on this so
the idea was already there but the two
kind of a decade before we could really
make it happen such that this could be
done efficient
so I would like the coming slides to
focus on the two most important
challenges that were kind of that were
in between 2003 and 2013 that prevented
people from really adopting this
technology
one of the key things was is that top
tier solvers like at the colon case set
but back then lingerling use kind of
about a dozen techniques that go uh
Beyond resolution or some of them modify
Solutions remove solutions they add
Solutions and some of them
allow exponential speed UPS
right one thing that we didn't want to
do is okay
everything that's not resolution just
turn it off and then you have your proof
right and what we really wanted to do
and this was when I started as a postdoc
with our main we want to have a single
proof rule that
does everything can we do all of the
reasoning in a thought solver using a
single roof
yeah
now although many of you saw this I
first want to kind of talk about is kind
of informally so what is a proof so
before going into into details what is a
proof a proof is simply a sequence of
Clauses that is redundant with respect
to the formula and the sequence ends at
the empty clause and this is similar
what uh so but Randy told in the morning
so what is redundant
we have the strongest notion of
redundancy a clause is redundant with
respect to a formula if adding it to the
formula preserve satisfied
yeah in that sense so in this strongest
notion of redundancy if we have an
insatisfiable formula everything is
written right because everything you add
doesn't change satisfiability
uh of course the other important thing
is that you should be able to check this
property in polynomial time and of
course that that uh that is kind of the
trick how can we have strong Notions of
redundancy that can be checkable and
problem your time
and I want to explain this using the
formula over here so this formula is
very simple and it's satisfiable but I
think it's much easier to explain this
using a satisfiable formula than uh
using unsatisfiable formula so we have
this simple formula and it has just two
solutions right B is true and a can be
either true or false
and what the things that subsovers are
able to do is add Clauses that remove
Solutions
and so what a solver could do is add a
clause like this
and so if we add this close to the
formula the number of solutions goes
from two to one and the question is okay
how are we going to check that reasoning
and a software that adds a clause like
this is valid
so again this is just the informal
definition and the example and the key
thing to make it all work is that we
only have a single proof
and the single proof rule is the one
shell of the slides
so and actually use Jacob's notation so
if we have a formula gamma and a clause
c a clause C is redundant with respect
to a formula gamma if there exists an
assignment such that the following holds
what's what the stated here if we have
an assignment that satisfies the formula
but falsifies the Clause then we can
turn this into an assignment that
satisfies the formula and the Clause
using the assignments
now uh let's we kind of explain to you
what is probably the easiest thing to
see why this holds is that say assume
that gamma is satisfiable and so comma
and C is satisfiable because that's
that's what we require so if gamma and c
is satisfiable then there exists a
satisfying assignment for gamma and c
and if there's a satisfying assignment
so then this simplifies to the empty
formula and the distributedly holds
but what we are interested in is okay
what are uh redundancy properties with
a Tau that is not a full assignment
right because this would actually mean
that we actually solve the full formula
and this is not going to help us with uh
uh solving fix so what we have and so
people that know drat is so tau is
indirect restricted to just an
assignment to a single variable
and so what we have in the in the
competitions we have this rule where
this is simplified to unit propagation
where tau is restricted to the
assignment to a single booty variant
and let me just show the you the example
so if we plug in this for this example
then we have this is our formula this is
the negation of our clause
and this is the formula and the clause
and now under the assignments
a to be true so that means they remove
all the Clauses satisfied and remove all
the force byte literals that simplifies
this into this which is a subset of the
formula and therefore uh and we can
check for example subsets efficiently
yeah so just to give you kind of a high
level that everything is possible using
the single rule
and uh and so we only need a checker
that is able to check this and so we
have a long proof say terabytes in size
but just a single rule that can be
checked
now let me kind of explain to you what
is possible using kind of the single
rule right and Randy mentioned this as a
simple math problem and of course it is
a simple math problem but I think it's a
very nice illustration of what's
possible
so which is the mutilated chessboard
what is the this problem we have a
chessboard and we take away the opposite
corner cells
and we ask whether the remaining grids
can be can be covered with dominoes that
cover two cells or two squares
what's the answer
yeah
what is the short argument two opposite
corner cells of a chessboard always have
the same color and every Domino covers
one white and one black and so if you
would try to do this
uh this will actually uh leave you with
two whites no matter how you do this
all right
now
um some interesting thing is if you now
because the nice thing about this
disproof rule is not only that it allows
you to have these proofs one of the cool
things that it revealed is all the kind
of additional reasoning that you can do
in a solver uh because we know okay what
is redundancy and how can we use this to
actually make this the reasoning in the
solver stronger and stronger
and if you would have this example over
here
and you would apply a conflict analysis
as described in couple of talks here
then what it will give you is so it says
okay this assignment is uh the one that
that you should block so all everything
else is actually is forced by unit
propagation and so you get a clause with
uh 14 electrons
if you go to kind of a stronger version
actually which is allowed by the
approval then and so which which we call
sdcl satisfaction driven close learning
what it gives back is actually this says
this is the reason
why uh the prior assignment was wrong
and you think okay how is that possible
why why why these two right but the
thing is that the reasoning here is
imagine that we have these two
horizontal Bonds on top of each other
and if there would be a way to finish
the whole thing then there is another
way to solve to solve the problem by
replacing the two horizontal ones by two
vertical ones and as a consequence we
can block two horizontal ones on top of
each other here and
everywhere on the grid
and so and this can be also easily be
expressed using the single peripheral
and more more specifically so if we have
the pattern uh two horizontal Dominoes
on top of each other we can replace them
by two vertical ones and therefore block
all two horizontal ones on top of each
other everywhere and
if there are two vertical ones before
horizontal one on top we can replace it
by two vertical ones and one horizontal
one below it if we block that pattern as
well the number of cases goes from
exponential to linear and we are done
and one of the key things that I I
noticed been solving uh lots of of math
problems is that
the computer is so automated reasoning
so severe difficulty coming up with the
chessboard pattern this is a very
complicated thing to come up with
however coming up with these kind of
local things it's much easier and so the
reasoning so it is able to come up with
a linear time argument for this kind of
problems but it's completely different
from uh What uh
humans would come up with although for
humans it's still understandable what's
going on
so I figured this out after looking at
the proof that the solver gave
um just to kind of also refer back to
what Randy said in the morning uh this
problem can also easily be solved uh
using bdds
and one of the cool things is also that
when we pointed out everything that this
can be done in a bdd solver can be
easily expressed using the same proof
rule right so although it's a completely
different way of solving problems
again this can easily be expressed using
the single proof rule
so the other challenge was the following
okay now we have the single proof row
now how are we going to check this
because do we want to give a little uh
so that you could add a lot of hints to
this why the closest redundant but what
we decided to do is okay
we have the single proof of everything
that is kind of learned by the solver
can be expressed by the sequence of
these of these uh of this redundancy but
how are we going to check this
efficiently
and uh because actually providing the
details was very costly so the so the
resolution proofs in the earlier work
producing them was very costly so what
we decided to do is okay we don't put
the burden of the details by the solver
what we're going to do is the Checker
needs to provide all the details
if you allow if you ask the Checker to
provide all the details then the cost of
checking explodes
how are we able to deal with this so we
are able to deal with this is by the
important observation here which was
already kind of mentioned in uh by
Goldberg in 2003 is we can reason
backwards
so the solver so we said blue is the
your formula and red is all the Clauses
that are learned by the solve
and what we can do is we at some point
just over derives the empty clause and
we don't need to check all of the Reds
right the only thing you need to check
is that we are able to reproduce the
empty clause
how are we going to do this so we start
with the empty clause and then we ask
okay what was required for the empty
course
and the interesting thing is the the
proofs that we have don't include any
hits
and this is actually an advantage
because if you would look at what the
solver case what the sulfur derives to
get the empty clause and you start
reasoning backwards then you get a quite
a big green part
but now we have the flexibility to okay
we have the empty clause and there's a
lot of Clauses the software learned how
can we reason backwards
Stark's death the things we need to
check is as small as possible and you
can do all kind of heuristics to really
make the green part as uh very small and
for many problems the green part is just
one percent of the of the of the the
servers produced by by the soil by the
dissolver and thereby you can make the
proof checking uh reasonably uh cheap
yeah so these were the the the two kind
key ideas
first have a single proof Rule and
second we are able to check things
efficiently by doing the backwards
reasoning using all kinds of heuristics
and so this is the kind of now the
current status is that we have formally
verified Checkers for this uh for this
strong proof systems and we don't have
to worry about the correctness or
completeness of Interest we're only
going to check for each results from the
solver whether uh
uh whether the result is correct and I
spoke to various uh software developers
and they said okay they're now daring to
kind of make the servers more and more
complex because they can check uh you
they can use the tools for debugging and
as a consequence the solvers have become
even more efficient
and so we can have now full uh
confidence in the results and these
Checkers are also used
also kind of give you a uh feeling of
kind of how how this is used so uh also
for many of the the math problems that
I've been working on uh this is kind of
the typical tool chain I have so we have
the original problem and first we encode
this
somehow into a propositional formula
this uh so far is typically the only
part of this not verified
uh and because it's not verified we want
to have this as simple as possible to to
have to have most confidence that this
part is correct
so we end up with our original formula
but because this is typically not the
easiest thing to solve
we want to transform it into a formula
that's easy to solve or easier to solve
and so what we do is we massage the
encoding in such a way that it becomes
much easier to solve so the the problem
I also explained two weeks ago we did
complete change of the encoding this
radical change of the encoding which is
way more complicated but allowed us to
have a factor 100 speed up
right so this part is done in the
re-encoding proof and then we solve the
problem which gets us a refutation we
combine the re-encoding and the
refutation then we optimize it such that
it's easy for the formerly verified
Checker and then we check it with the
formerly verified check
and so this is the approach I've mostly
been taken even for the Pythagorean
triples you write a seven line C program
that generates this then we
re-encode it to get something which is
easier to solve and then reconstruct the
entire output
yeah
and so uh yeah so I already mentioned
this uh
uh these kind of topics okay now let's
go beyond proof validation so we can now
conserve this proofs we can check them
to be correct what can we get other
things out of can we get some insight
out of it
I want to explain this using uh the
chromatic number of the plane so what is
this problem so we have all the points
in the two-dimensional space and there's
only one constraint if two points have
exactly distance one they must have a
different color
so how many colors do you need
so this problem was already kind of the
Statics uh around the 1950 and already
kind of in the late 40s early 50s these
results were known
namely you need at least four colors and
at most second colors what is the
argument so you have these seven points
in the plane shown over here with 11
distances one and this graph known as
the motor spindle has chromatic number
four if there are already seven points
then it must at least hold for the for
the entire plane uh uh that you have
this lower bound and the upper bound
comes from the tiling of the plane using
hexacom tiles with the hexagon slightly
smaller than outer radius than one such
that two points within a tower that
cannot be two points within it out and
two towns of the same color are further
apart
yeah so this was already known in 1950
and it took uh practically 70 years to
make progress on this
and so operator gray was the first one
to find a
graph of
158136 that has chromatic number five
and uh so when he got the results he
approached the media the media
approached called Harrison by then a
colleague at UT Austin and Scott said
okay I'm not I cannot check this but you
can probably check this and if you can
check it you can probably do better so
that's what I did in the
in the weeks afterwards I tried to find
smaller and smaller graphs
using uh reverse of chromatic number
five
and I was able to do this and I will
explain this in a couple a couple of
slides next by looking at proofs the
proofs kind of allowed me to to make
smaller and smaller graphs
so let me go a bit into detail so
the first part was the validation so
there's two things that we need to do
for validation the first thing is that
if you have two points that you have to
check that the distance is actually one
right and this is also Daniela we did
this uh back then so we used the grubner
basis approach
um to to make sure that the distance is
exactly one and this is kind of the
typically how these points look like in
the play
the second part of course is that we
need to check the chromatic number
the chromatic number we know how to
check this right we make a formula we
ask if it's five colorable that's easy
and we also ask whether there is no four
coloring and so we ask is there four
coloring and the answer should be in
satisfied
now the key thing to observe is that the
unsatisfiable core so all the Clauses
that are required to prove in
satisfiability they form another graph
that has chromatic number five
all of the vertices that are not
mentioned in the proof or in the
unsatisfiable core they can be removed
and you still have the chromatic number
five
now what I try to do and so is uh how
can we get the smallest unsatisfiable
and I have been trying all kind of
existing tools but existing tools
completely broke down on this
uh and uh how do you get a small one and
actually I implemented two algorithms
the first one is the one shown here the
second one is on the next slide and the
second one works way better but I just
want to kind of give you some idea what
my first approach was what's what was
shown over here
and uh then how can we do better
so what we do is we start with our
formula and we we want to Output an
unsatisfiable core
so we solve the formula that we obtain a
proof then there's all kind of ways to
optimize proofs I don't want to go into
detail here but there's all kind of ways
to optimize proofs and make it smaller
and smaller
and once we kind of done with that we
can extract a core from the proof
and then we can use the core we can
solve the core again get another proof
minimize the proof and so on right and
at some point there is no progress
anymore and then you give up
so this was my the the results I showed
initially were based on this algorithm
you have to we have somehow a very big
graph with chromatic number five and we
get smaller and smaller and smaller
one of the things that I noticed and
that was also the the reason why uh
hopefully the grave was not able to get
smaller if you sometimes if you remove a
clause then the runtime of the solver
can really explode so if you give it a
big graph it maybe takes a couple of
seconds if you take away the wrong
vertex the runtime can go from seconds
to hours
but it still has problematic number five
but it becomes very expensive
and once you have so hit such a Vertex
you at some point you cannot really
reduce it anymore
so one of the the things I noticed and
this works actually uh turned out to
work really well and it was kind of a
big kind of an interesting observation
is the following
so we have our proof
we
make it as small as possible
and so and
then the interesting thing is we are
going to run this again so optimize the
proof again but now with the original
formula so we first had uh and the the
key observation is that any proof for a
subset of the formula is also a proof
for the original formula right and the
nice thing about this proof rule is that
uh so for drat and other proof systems
is that you don't mention any hints so
it's a very general thing and anything
all the proofs that work for uh
uh yeah so for supersets
for our subset is also working for
superset and that way what happens if
you use this algorithm is that uh
you can extract put get Clauses that are
from the original formula you can pull
them back in to get smaller and smaller
cores yeah right
there's a property that uh well it if
you have a subset it also works for the
the whole set
um it assumes that you're not using your
redundancy too much or not witnessing on
from variables too much yeah no so in
this case so for for the proofs here are
are just uh I I used these are just uh
cdcl resolutions okay
um
but
you start with f to come from a graph
but then F core also coming from another
graph no no
at core is is so f is is just the the
the graphing code of the graph coloring
encoding of of a photograph
and the core is just whatever closes are
mentioned in the proof
well there's no the graphs disappeared
from the
the picture then I mean you you didn't
find it your previous slide it it seemed
to say that you had a graph of 810
vertices instead of 1500 vertices yeah
so so where does that graph come from
yeah so I didn't want to kind of
um discuss whether how I constructed the
graphs but the graphs have thousands of
vertices the original ones that we
started with and then the debts are our
Formula F is initially discussing
thousands of vertices and then we get
down down down from there
but yeah so since this is a talk about
uh uh trust and proofs I didn't want to
describe all the complicated ways to
just do to construct these graphs
yeah but so the core so the core is just
a subset of the closest so which means
the subset of the edges and a subset of
the vertices
uh and in but in the end what we have
the when we extract uh the sub graph we
just look at the dimensions vertices in
the in the
in the final chord
so are you going to say any more words
on how you actually
so yeah no uh let me so the question is
how do you pull back Clauses from uh
from the original formula that's done
fully automatic I don't make any kind so
what I I do say I run deret trim
using the proof and the the proof
produced on the core
and I give it the same I give the proof
again to Diva trim but with the original
formula and I use all kind of heuristics
in Diva trim to make the the proof
smaller
and everything goes automatically
because it it just has a super set of
the of the Clauses and it it is able
then to pull them back in so you don't
have any special heuristics I have no
special risk so it's just I just gave it
another input formula and then it's able
to uh to pull things back in but without
any guidance yes
any other questions
now just to give you uh
uh a little bit of an impression of how
this this works is so this is uh the
number of iterations uh and so with
different sheets I run this if you do
the naive way then you get down to kind
of uh 500 for a part of the graph and
you get substantially smaller if you use
the option to pull back closest backing
and so uh I was able to get smaller and
smaller graphs by
using this algorithm and I tried to find
to use other tools to find small cores
but none of the tools were able to get
uh even course in the range of this and
the algorithm I just showed is able to
give you kind of what is it uh
two very few awareness for longer I
guess it gives you about 50 Clauses
smaller or 50 30 smaller graphs
and especially for people that are
interested in uh in mugshots and other
play other areas where cores are
important
uh you can use this algorithm to get
smaller and smaller cores and I think
that that that is also might be quite
helpful for applications such as
Microsoft ecoline so there's a array of
techniques used for core minimization
that are not based on proofs
are any of those techniques
would you be able to use any of those
techniques in conjunctions
so that's like this model rotation
so I use the tools
[Music]
that are available but so to compute and
to compute and satisfy minimal and
satisfiable core using existing tools
which uses model rotation and this and
and the the problem is with all these
tools is at some point they they decide
to take out a take out the clause
and when they take out a random Clause
then
the proof explodes and then the
resulting core will be large
and so the issue is with all these
techniques is that they somehow they're
always relying on getting randomly
picking out some claws that they remove
instead of doing everything based on
proofs because the nice thing here is
that the proofs
are always
they're always small right they're
they're actually kilobytes in size
typically
and by keeping by following keeping this
this procedure you make sure that if you
make a mistake anywhere you can always
kind of get back because you were able
to pull back things back in
but you know if you I'm if you're able
to to get a smaller graph I would be
very happy if you could show that I
don't think so in my experience the
other techniques don't work
and they don't combine
what and they don't even combine no no
they do compound what do you mean
um
I don't know how how to how to combine
this uh I'm asking you yeah no yeah no
foreign
based on proofs
yeah no I think I think uh I'm hopeful
that this also why I included this topic
because there are several marks of
people on the room right uh that I think
this could be quite helpful uh uh there
because the as at least in my experience
is that other existing techniques are
not able to get this kind of goals
I'm sorry I I I feel dumb but uh you you
we're talking about a car which consists
of Clauses yeah and then you're talking
about graphs would have vertices yeah
but then we also have colors yeah and
the Clauses have to do with colors and
not and then you say you added 131
vertices
yeah okay so so so I I I don't see
you know you you're removing Clauses in
order to get a small core yeah but but
but but then then what uh you you remove
a Vertex because it no longer depends in
any of the Clauses or something yeah so
uh the the classical I saw the graph
following encoding that I use has for
each vertex it has at least one color
and for every Edge for every uh Edge
that the 230 says mentioned cannot have
the same color so as soon as uh
a clause that says each vertex has to
have at least one color is no longer in
the core then you know that you can
safely take that vertex out and still
have the the the the the the the desired
property is our property meaning that
they're all distance one no the desired
property meaning chromatic number five
then why do you have to add 131
yeah so yeah so
actually I yeah no this is the I see the
the confusion here uh the thing is that
I split the graph into two because I am
able to to to to to minimize the the
parts independently but yeah so uh I
let me just Let's ignore that that part
so I'm actually minimizing two two uh uh
graphs at the same time that I can
combine
thank you
so and this is the smallest graph I was
able to produce so far so I got down to
510.
um which is vertex critical only the
middle one for example has the fifth
color and everything else
as uh the other four colors and so the
lines denotes distance one so this is
distance one and what you kind of see in
these kind of smallest examples is that
uh 30 states that are close to each
other tend to have the same color right
which looks a bit like the the original
tiling but of course we just have here
four colors plus the fifth color for
justice in overtakes
yeah and yeah I'm re if anybody so I'm
I'm still quite hopeful that we at some
point get to Chromatic number six and
I'm working on this uh uh and I have
several ideas maybe how together but I
think this is also a important challenge
for automated reasoning can we get to
Chromatic number six and I think it
should be the world
comedy number seven seems to be
completely out of reach uh
for several reasons about six I think is
probably doable
okay let's go to the next topic so this
was kind of another math problem that I
uh looked into
um is uh Keller's conjection what's
scalar's conjecture is we have square
tiles all of the same size and we want
to have a tiling of the two-dimensional
space without gaps
and the question is can we do this while
avoiding the two adjacent
South fully sharing Edge
if you think about it then the only way
of doing this is to put a gap-free
tiling is to put the tiles into lanes
lanes can be shifted arbitrarily from
each other but two tiles within a lane
fully sharing Edge
right that's also shown over here so we
have Lanes but two tiles that are in the
same Lane adjacent fully shared
we can ask the same question for the
three-dimensional case so we have cubes
all of the same size
and we want to do it a dialing of the
three-dimensional space so there's no
gaps now I try to do this here using a
couple of Cubes but the the faces you
see over here the blue ones the only way
that I can continue is to make them
fully share the face
and so it you need to think about it
slightly longer but then you also come
to the conclusion that the only way of
doing this is that there are cubes that
fully share effects
now Keller conjectured in 1930 that this
happens for all Dimensions so it's not
only one two and three but for all
Dimensions it holds that if you have
n-dimensional pukes
and you tell the n-dimensional space
without gaps then you always have an N
minus one
uh dimensional face sharing between two
cubes
and we were able to solve this problem
using uh sort and this is this this
problem seems way more different right
because how are we going to this is a
continuous styling problem
how are we going to discretize it and so
we were able to do this building on top
of a lot of work that has been done uh
over the century that this problem is
out
um and so the conclusion was here that
the conceptual holds up till Dimension 7
and it breaks at Dimension eight and and
up as soon as you have a counter example
for a certain Dimension then that is a
counter example also for all higher
dimensions
so I won't talk about how we how we were
able to encode this but you can imagine
that this is way more tricky than the
Pythagorean triples
and uh the key thing is so
how can we be sure that everything that
we did because it was also a big
computation how can we be sure that this
result is correct
and so because we this is a continuous
styling problem so how do we discretize
it
then there is this the key symmetry
breaking depends on that the conjecture
holds for the prior dimension
how can we
kind of make sure that okay that holds
right and then the encoding was
complicated
but so our Solutions and so I think this
is an important thing for future things
is that we
validate everything but we need to do
this uh for example with uh in interfere
Improvement so
uh Josh Clune
formalized the discretization of the
problem so this has been there's a lot
of work in this and he formalized the
entire argument going from The
Continuous statements to the Keller
graphs
we need to kind of a verified way of and
that a student is now working on this if
we have an insult result from one
formula what does it mean for another
formula and how can we make sure that
the results from one formula if we know
this is inside what can we derive from
this for the other one so how do we do
communication between such results
and the same student is also working on
a verifying gear code
and I think it is important so this
these are things though that cannot be
expressed in with the single peripheral
right this is all kind of on a higher
level and to be sure that these these
map results are uh that you can fully
trust them we need
this one these results verified as well
cool deep so what do you mean by
verifying the encoding you have a
problem statement in what language and
so in this case so I I don't didn't talk
about what's what the
the problem in the end is a question
about does a certain graph have a c
click of another of a certain size
and
um but it's more complicated than that
but so we have a statement in lean that
describes this this problem and then the
uh
produce the propositional formula that
and then we show that this that if this
is unsatisfiable then the click does not
exist
so a statement like a first time
and therefore Dimension eight oh so uh
don't mention that for Dimension a
there's no frequent so the but your
point is that once there is a counter
example right that counter example can
be checked efficiently uh uh but the
same as any such results can can be
checked efficiently but the key thing is
that that it does hold for Dimension
seven was the the big the biggest uh
combinatorial problems yeah just so that
I understand so you have like a first
order sentence and you are trying to
verify whether you Encore whether you're
grounded into the preposition formula
yes correctly okay
and so I think this is
um really important and also if we want
to kind of convince others that these we
can solve this this big open math
problems especially if we go beyond kind
of uh natural kind of combinatorial
problems uh we need to also very
validate the encoding and uh which has
typically multiple things and this I
think all three of them will typically
be part of that is that we need to uh
discretize it we need to probably do
some communication between formulas and
we need to verify the encodes
now there's another thing that I wanted
to talk about uh based on the
discussions we had on Saturday bill and
I
um
about the uh end Queen graph so the
graph has n Square vertices
corresponding to each of the cells of
the M by n board and
um chessboard and two there's an edge
between two cells if they if Queens on
those cells can attack each other yeah
or if you could see different if you you
can get from a queen from one side of
the other one
uh so most people have been looking into
the problem okay can we put Greens on
there but you can also ask this graph
whether what is the chromatic number of
this graph
and so here's a five by five one which
can be you you just need uh five colors
right and the the
fire so and for the end Queens it's
clearly that you need at least n ones
because you need to have an every row
column and dialect
um so what's the chromatic number and so
you see that for most of them it is uh
the same but for some of them it's it's
like it's one higher so you you you you
need uh n plus one chords
and I have been looking at all kind of
so I had a paper on graph coloring uh
uh last year at flock and this turned
out to be out very difficult problems
right to to show those eight knob but
nine and ten are really challenging
and so we discussed this also um and it
turns out and so this is a very cool
idea it's about uh click hints
and so you can actually solve these
problems now efficiently by so-called
click hits so what is a click hint is
that
for every click of size n and so that
means every row and every column and
both diagonals we know that every caller
needs to appear there right if we want
to color different colors
and we can add this as constraints
right we can add this okay and orange
needs to be here orange needs to be
there right orange needs to be there
and
um
and yeah so this is a very elegant idea
and so I I did not think about it in the
past and so I implemented this and now
these problems actually become easy so
and if you imagine what happens now if
you don't have these Clauses so uh
somehow the assignment says okay in this
row there cannot be any Orange
right somehow with your existing
assignment then you end up with a
pigeonhole formula right because one
color is out and you need and but you
might be able the solver will might try
to to fix it right
and so you end up with as soon as one
caller is excluded from every click
you uh might be solving a pigeonhole
forward
and
um
so but now so also why I wanted to uh to
mention this okay these are very
powerful Clauses so for example for
eight it goes from uh four seconds say
to to zero to two seconds but I'm now
able to solve all of them so for 10 it
is now I can do this now in uh I think
in 40 minutes but I was not able to
solve 10 at all
right yeah and so you can now solve
these problems using these Clauses but
how do I justify them right we can of
course bring maybe do some pigeonhole or
there's other other ways of doing this
but it's more in in in general
if we come up with very cool ideas of
how to speed things up how are we sure
that that these things are correct right
and we probably also want to have some
uh verified statements that these things
are correct
yeah and I really like this idea so I'm
I think there's more things that click
hints can be useful for for kind of all
kind of graphs and so thanks so much for
bringing this up
and so to to conclude
um
proof locking is now mature in such uh
all the top tiers over supported uh we
can even check these results with
formerly verified Checkers and as Randy
also mentioned there haven't been any
issues with solvers in uh in the last
couple of years right so software
developers are using them and we almost
don't need to check the results anymore
because the solvers the tools are now
highly trustworth
yeah because everybody uses it I do
think that
we need also where the community focuses
on CNF formulas but in practice because
they these CNF formulas come from
somewhere
right and if we really want to have full
confidence in the results we need also
to verify that the encoding circuit and
that we actually solve something on the
original problem and there's a lot of
cool stuff
in this area that I think there's some
talks also like this afternoon
a lot of cool stuff trying to kind of
generalize with proofs what's going on
on such we also now see it in smt in
model counting max out and so this is
the the paper from last year but Randy
also mentioned that we have uh making
quite some progress also in this
direction of formerly verified Mobile
County
um that concludes my talk uh thanks so
much
all right questions
oh yeah there's another slide if they
live there's time basically two more
slides but
it's like seriously
no no no this slide 32.
um so this is the one of the slides I
wanted to show you uh so this is we run
uh
all of the winners so this is the
winners from 2002 from the first
subconscious to 2020 this is the winners
of the main track or the industrial
track and we rent them on all the
benchmarks of the 2020 competition
and so how to redisclose for anybody who
doesn't have seen this before so if this
is the timeout how many problems would
you have solved
and so what you see here for example
limit was able to solve slightly more
than 50 problems in 5000 seconds
uh while uh cassette was able to do the
same thing in say a couple of hundred
seconds or maybe two or three
milliseconds
and so what I also did here is I sorted
the solvers based on the performance on
the 2020 Suite
and you see it's almost
chronologically ordered right and what
you do see of course uh you take another
set and it's there's a slight shuffling
but what you see here is that there is
clear progress none of these solvers
have seen the benchmarks right uh we
have 300 benchmarks that are completely
new and 100 benchmarks from uh say from
the 6000 that have been used in Prior
competitions
um and I think this is a really cool
thing that that we have these plots for
multiple competitions and what you see
is that if you sort things based on the
number of benchmarks they solve it's
almost a chronological source and so
there has been steady progress
um and we are and if you look at the
competition reports that that that the
organizers that make we frequently also
are able to pinpoint kind of what are
the technique or techniques that really
were able to uh to improve
so
um I think I think this is pretty
compelling evidence that there has been
progress over the years
I never doubted the progress I'm still
saying that I have to go and look
somewhere to figure out why cassette
2020 was able to have such a such a jump
do you know why
what what particular feature in cassette
was the reason for this that's what I'm
you know so I think local search was was
an important thing but mate also pointed
out so local search was important here
but cassette is also
the implemented much more efficiently
than the implementation
no no but I think the locals but there's
okay set is
it changed yeah all right
I I don't remember it still but he he
changed the data structures uh based on
his experience so he knew where the fat
was he improved he wasn't the only
algorithm change but but it was also
just uh his intimate knowledge with with
the performance of the previous
implementations yeah although I think
the algorithmic improvements were much
more important than the the the the
implementation details but of course you
all know that Armin is able to to
implement things better than everybody
except maybe desire
so one of the things was this
diversification and intensification that
that that I believe Armin was sort of on
top of at this point uh and got it right
kind of
um this is this thing with V6 versus
vmtf so this is not the only one going
around town now so there's this vmtf
versus
um and also a commensurate change in
resource strategy and polarity heuristic
which also came together with local
search so did they do integrate and
interact with each other and sometimes
unknown ways and that is right that we
need to look into that but it's more
than just it's more than just getting
the data structures right so there's
some like real work here
I I I think he also left out some other
Improvement that that weren't pulling
their weight uh
and that's actually kind of speed up in
time
because he was taking time to to make
improve but but okay
well I've got the mic
I just want to say you you were too kind
to me about this cook hints because I
got the idea of Click hints from a
manager fan uh and and I I improved his
ideas slightly but but in the wrong
direction because I was using a
different encoding and
so I converted it into something
complicated I called double clickings
and I showed double click kids to you
and you simplified it and made an order
of magnitude Improvement so yeah
I don't know I thought it was a very
natural step step in the next step but I
am I wouldn't never have come up with it
if you didn't bring it up and I think
yeah okay
thank you
other questions
so one of your slides you you showed
that
you'd re-encode the problem and then you
validate the re-encoding
so in the talk that you gave a couple of
weeks back the
and that was a very very different
re-encoding right yeah so how do you
validate I mean from
original encoding which was is
completely different so in this case we
so
um yeah please so do we have the status
paper which is also on my website but
it's just a you can express the entire
although you can if you have the
original encoding you can have the new
encoding is you can just have is
everything is implied by or implied by
direct can be checked by d-reads and
then you can just drop the everything
that was no longer necessary from the
original encoding so d-bred allows you
to just
uh reformulate it
in a very straightforward manner
so so you're saying the the new encoding
is
kind of derivable from the original
encoding if you know the right yeah so
there is a you need to have the right
order in which you enter Clauses but the
entire uh re-encoder's formula can be
added without any auxiliary Clauses if
you add them in the right order
and uh in my experience that that's
frequently possible to have the
optimized encoding or the re-encoded one
is just you can add them with direct
steps
and typically without any auxiliary
clauses
last question perhaps
okay so if you want to know because
actually I have another breakup slide
um that was this counter articles out
today on the on that that problem uh so
and it's uh it kind of also describes
kind of how the background story of that
problem so that the one that I discussed
so if you look Google that I guess it's
already also check if Google can
probably find it after a couple of hours
yeah
okay thank you so much
[Applause]